(gentle music)
- I remember the first
time that I snorkel.
We jump in the water and
we saw many colorful fish.
And it was unbelievable.
So since then I wanted to
repeat that experience again.
It wasn't until I turned 24
when I had the opportunity
to travel all around the
Baja California Peninsula.
And that was the moment that I realized
that I wanted to be an explorer.
My name is Octavio Aburto.
I am a conservation biologist
and a National Geographic Explorer.
(gentle music)
I am study mangroves.
Mangroves are trees that live
where the ocean meets the coast.
And they are special because
they grow in saltwater.
Here in Mexico, I think we have
the most beautiful mangroves
in all the planet.
They are not only beautiful,
they provide a lot of economic benefits
for coastal communities.
The mangrove roots come into the water,
and they form a refuge
for many, many baby fish.
Then they can live inside
these roots like a nursery.
It's like a playground for them.
(upbeat music)
I just saw a big school of
snappers and a lot of parrotfish.
These juveniles only live
here inside the mangroves,
and eventually when they grow up
they will supply the fish
markets here in La Paz city.
(water gurgling)
Mangroves protect coastal areas
against hurricanes and erosion.
They also filter water
for many coastal towns,
and provide essential
habitat for many species.
(gentle music)
Unfortunately in the last 50 years,
we have lost half of
the mangroves worldwide.
And this is because of
agriculture, shrimp farming,
coastal development, and pollution.
The first step to help mangroves
is to know how much mangrove we have
in order to tackle this problem.
My research involves two techniques.
One is counting everything that we have
inside the mangrove roots,
and the other branch of our research
is to estimate the cover of the mangroves.
To estimate the mangrove
cover, we are using drones.
(upbeat music)
(drone beeping)
With drone technology, we
are surveying areas faster,
and it's giving us a new perspective.
(drone whirring)
We fly at different heights,
at 100 meters and 10 meters,
and we take a lot of images.
Later we use all of these images
to create a composite image
that is called orthomosaic.
So you can use or we can use these images,
not only to estimate the area,
also the volume of the forest.
Using all this data, now we know where are
all these mangrove areas,
how many animals live there,
and we can set conservation priorities
to protect this beautiful life.
The involvement of local
communities is essential
to stop mangrove deforestation.
If they understand that these
roots protect their towns,
create habitat for the fish that they sell
in the fish markets, we will
have not only more mangrove
in the future, we will have
more economic benefits for them,
and for the rest of the country.
Mangroves represent a very,
very tiny area in this planet,
(gentle music)
but they provide a huge
amount of services for humans.
So we need to protect them
for the future generations.
(water gurgling)